I'm a married man I'm a married man I'm
a married man I'm a married man I'm a
married man I'm a married man I'm a
married man
everyone's age because I'm very young
I'm only 22.
very young I'm 29. okay I'm 27. I'll be
28. I'll be 28 25 33 almost okay baby
so how did everybody propose so I took
her back to uh Boston which is where he
went to school took her in front of a
dorm where we first met that's where we
first met a person because before that I
slid in the DM into Facebook by the way
guys we did like a little Bollywood
flash mob in front of the dorm yeah yeah
that's actually nice yeah yeah that's
pretty cool well uh he proposed on the
Santa Monica Pier because it's one of my
favorite locations on my birthday so I'm
from Colombia he's from L.A okay and we
went back and forth and then when I came
that time he proposed and then we had to
do that whole immigration thing as well
so yeah she really wanted to take a
couple photos like at the time and then
we like went and like did like a photo
shoot and then like she had like her
back turned to like towards the camera
and like I had like the ring and then
like when she turned it on and I popped
the question I love it I was actually
active duty for my first year and my
wife actually decided to join so for
graduation I propose a graduation uh I
mean it worked out just only because her
family was going to be there in my
family was gonna be there for graduation
took her to our first date spot which
was the Gaylord Hotel it was under a
really nice gazebo and there were like
snowflakes coming out in the background
and everything because they were doing
some event and that's where I proposed
her nice I told her that my sister
wanted to do a shoot with her so when
the photographer was like taking photos
of them I just showed up with the ring I
was like oh hey man yeah so like they
were taking photos of us anyway and then
mine I didn't really propose it was like
arranged but I mean we just agreed to it
she actually lives in Pakistan right now
yeah it's a little long distance thing
yeah is that because you guys are
waiting on uh like immigration stuff
yeah man that's rough is it hard doing
the whole long long distance 100 texting
and stuff and then night time oh yeah
yeah
[Music]
foreign
guy so I I thought in my head I was like
oh this guy's definitely an F boy
and he just carries this like nervous
energy I feel like when we started the
game just the pauses and like the little
nervous energy really made me like
suspicious of him
he looks like a boy what does an
F boy look like to you nose piercings
um
maybe a hat that's pretty much it
and we actually have a tie
Andy wow and Justin
we're gonna have you talk a little bit
about marriage both of you will have 30
seconds to do so I've been married for a
little over six years I want to say the
first year was like the hardest year I'm
like a family guy so having to like kind
of EX not excommunicate but like
distance myself from my family so like
it was like literally just like me and
my wife like best friends
um that's like where like the majority
of like our growth has come from just
like really just like separating myself
from like my family
um six years later we have two beautiful
daughters
um three and one I think the biggest
thing I learned
um you know going into marriage was the
importance of communication and my wife
really helped me kind of learn those
things with trial and error I think
communication is the number one thing in
any relationship let alone marriage and
I know this is completely irrelevant but
what I'm saying is I'm trying to get
um you guys to understand they're like I
know what the most important thing in
marriage is into this communication who
would like to vote Andy out
good luck I believe you you are a
married man I believe you
so what is an F4 to you guys I don't
like think of like a CIS male like a
straight man that's just like what I've
always thought of like when I thought
about like an F boys I think a boy
is somebody that like leads people on
right in order to get them to to do
whatever right like I don't think it's
as simple as just someone that has a lot
of Partners right because that that's
totally fine as long as all parties
that's the arrangement that they want it
was just like really confident in like
his answers of like what an F boy was
and I was like this is the guy he was
like saying all like the right answers
he was gonna say mine's pretty much the
same definition someone who's just using
you for the time being for whatever
um the reason is I guess like to you
guys is it like why why do people would
need to go for the emotional aspect to
get like the sexual part like why don't
you just go for that well I think that's
what it is they don't there's no emotion
yeah yeah but what do you just say like
hey I want this and that's it well that
would be a good person yeah
well it's just like if you want to go on
a hookup with people you're kind of like
straightforward with it just text
someone say like hey you're down yes
yeah but like I don't need to go and say
like oh you know I'm thinking of wanting
a relationship and I see myself with you
to kind of like get you into that can we
be fair though to be honest though it's
kind of both the ways if you think about
it like the reason we have boys is why
good men like actually you know I mean
like yeah I appreciated yeah and just
like if we remove that entirely then I
feel like the standards will be even
higher in a way do you understand what
I'm saying I understand that makes sense
right you're kind of saying like sunny
days wouldn't be special Without Rain
kind of thing right exactly but but at
the same time though if our status quo
is that everybody was a good person I
don't think it would be that way as
Humanity we would just be like oh sweet
everybody's good I can trust anyone
really you think I think so yeah are you
all uh monogamous yeah like yeah no yeah
open relationship yeah my culture will
not allow for that what's your body
count can I ask that all right no no we
talk about it we talk about it yeah okay
I said one my wife yeah growing up yeah
and and for me like grew up like in like
the Christian like home and so I knew
that like it was gonna be like my wife I
was gonna save myself for marriage and
all that stuff and I got made fun of a
lot like being like working like um I
mean just like the warehousing
environment but I'm just like I know
what I want and it worked out in the end
I was too I'm actually Christian too but
my wife was actually my second body so
she wasn't my first yeah I was just
trying to catch somebody flipping like
that I'm not trying to shame anybody I'm
not trying to like yeah
[Music]
I unintentionally intentionally
proceeded to give him side eyes anytime
I could I was like you're the mole I
felt as though Justin was very
suspicious of me he seems like he's
going to want to eliminate me at some
point so I'm gonna just try to eliminate
him right now
wow wow so Justin will have you step out
of the box and then just come take a
seat I trusted some of you guys just
some of you guys
if you think the mole is still in the
box and you like to continue the game
please raise your hand
why all right just come on I'm actually
fairly confident that we don't have them
all here I'm like maybe 90 because
somebody could be a really good actor
there's a reason I'm certain and I want
to call it out next round so I I just
have a student okay all right
all right okay there's two people I'm
really like cautious but I'm more
cautious about Cyrus because of the
reactions I feel like from last like
questioning about the boy it seemed like
he kind of like took it to heart he was
like but why would you view it that way
and I was like why is he that is a
pretty solid Point yeah and then also no
offense but I feel like you haven't
spoken about anything and I can't
remember why you got married or how yeah
let's ask yeah what's your in-laws names
uh John and Tina they're both deaf so
like I have to sign it to them okay oh
really got you so I learned sign
language all right so immediately I
trust him because that's a up
thing to lie yeah yeah
that would be yeah did you did you you
said you said that you served in
military right yeah I'm still active
duty too yeah
yes that's also up to lie about
so he's not he's not mine
um so what do you want to know I know
you talked about like being in a
long-distance relationship but like when
like how did it start to go more in
detail well so we met in 2018 we met on
Tinder I was in Columbia he lived in La
you know we kind of started saying oh we
should meet in person which is pretty
insane I know a lot of people were like
wow you're just gonna go to another
country to meet someone so we met here
and then he visited to Colombia he met
my family then I came back next year and
then we got married and then when we had
to do the whole immigration process
um that was like the climax it was one
thing that you found out after you guys
were married that you didn't know like
before home household kind of Dynamics
like you do your things one way I do it
my way but my wife she's very structural
so she likes things done like this this
one time and me I'm kind of like a
procrastinator so that is kind of an
argument sometimes it's the opposite way
in my house really I'm the structured
one oh really yeah what is structured
because like sometimes I'll clean the
toilets and then she'll like go and
reclaim the toilets no yeah because yeah
I don't do a good enough job of yeah
around the house has any way ever
attempted to lead you on
um no not really were you one before you
got married no I wouldn't say that I
mean I've like like
no I mean like I've hooked up with
people you know but I wouldn't I
wouldn't with that description we kind
of agreed on with the emotional part I
never thought that that's like a
necessity but I feel like I disagreed on
it and that's why you respect yourself
okay let me explain about that so it was
more about curiosity about how straight
culture works because to me that's very
alien but you don't think in another
Community there there are F there can't
be but like it's somebody that let's say
that you're like 25 hookups in a week I
wouldn't say that's a boy like a
wooden classic I would have put that in
labor no like no no no no no no
that is wow I also feel like
literally dude both I guess okay wait
wait wait if you're changing the
definition then by that definition then
yes that person will be a boy so
it's semantics at this point yes do you
guys get it get along with those in-laws
yeah oh 100 that's the big thing yeah
that's a big thing yeah that could
honestly make a break of marriage yeah
how'd you and your uh we used to work
together it was a hotel near Disneyland
I was at the front desk yeah yeah do you
think boys are cool yes or no no
okay
oh yeah
[Music]
if you think the mole is still in the
box and you wish to continue the game
please raise your hand
I don't trust anyone so I'm just going
to think that you don't have to go with
it it's always got trust issues all
right so that means the game is over
and we'll go into the reveal bro if it's
clovers I'm back flipping out of here
bro like I'm gonna yes I'm gonna smash
my face into the wall dog if the lights
turn green that means that you have
and you all win
but if the lights turn red that means
that the mole is still in the box and
you all lose in three
two one
[Music]
I don't know who it is I'm pretty sure
it's you dude
well the more please reveal themselves
in three
two
one
[Music]
dude
he's deflecting bro every time it comes
over here he's like oh yeah he'd be like
a married man
you have a significant other that's
active duty I don't so that that person
so uh like I was hearing your guys
definitions of an F boy right someone
who doesn't care manipulates no feelings
right uh and I feel as if that's a big
broad term because I do have feelings
for for other people uh I just would
rather be single right now and focus on
my career I can respect that yeah I
guess I'm classified as an F boy but I
just enjoy being single don't lead
anybody on everybody knows up front you
know I just want to be single
foreign
[Music]
marriage has been wonderful
um I definitely I love being married my
wife Michelle is my inspiration I get
challenged by her every day in the best
way possible and she just really
motivates me to be a better man it's
hard it's tough but if you communicate I
felt that to make our love stronger
really even after a fight actually makes
it grow